Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Da bin ich wieder.
Ich war jetzt nicht so lange weg, ne?
Drei Stunden.
Hackerman-Time.
Ne, ich hab mich bisschen bewegt.
Chat-Gip.
Chat, Chat, Chat.
Ganz wichtig.
Ganz wichtig, Chat.
Es ist jetzt 16.11 Uhr.
Um 17 Uhr
muss ich meine Pillen abends nehmen.
Denkt mal
please mit dran,
dass ich meine Pillen nehme
um 17 Uhr.
Wir bräuchten jetzt noch ein Emote dafür.
Es gibt ja Max ans Trinken erinnern.
Bräuchten wir sowas wie Max an die Pillen erinnern.
17 Uhr.
war mal kurz die vm an und wir machen wir package updates und weil das immer
funktioniert bei 8 linux bei the way ab timer gestellt sehr gut chat exzellent
euch kann man sich verlassen übrigens guckte mal hier
Du mal hier, meine, das ist die Wasserdruckanzeige an meiner Heizung im Keller.
Wisst ihr was?
Chat-GPT ist ja da richtig schlecht, aber schauen wir mal, ob Chat-GPT besser geworden ist.
Wo muss man das hin kopieren? Hier rein irgendwie, ne?
Oh, Windows-Dreck und
Drop, Alter. Die Methode liegt auf Dreck.
Okay.
Äh.
Wer ist denn Desktop? Das ist, der ist fast sauber. Moment,
Moment. Der hier, ja, ja.
Schlimm, ne?
Ähm.
Das ist eine Anzeige
für Wasser
Heizung.
Auf welchem Wert
steht sie?
So, mal gucken,
ob das besser geworden ist.
Ja, das ist eine Anzeige
für den Wasser. Ja, mhm, mhm, mhm.
Der Zeiger steht auf 1,1
Bar.
Das können die Dinger nicht.
Das können die Dinge einfach nicht.
Möchtest du, dass ich dir erkläre,
wie du das Nachbefüllen richtig machst?
Da bin ich mal gespannt,
wie ChatGPT das wissen will.
Manometer, ja, das heißt wirklich so.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ja.
Erkläre mir es bitte,
als wäre ich fünf.
Heizung ausschalten, nicht, dass sie gerade pumpt.
Der erste Schritt ist schon falsch, Alter.
Der erste Schritt ist schon falsch.
Ich muss die Heizung nicht ausschalten dafür.
Welcher Nachfüllschlauch?
Zweiter Schritt ist auch falsch.
Ja, Wasser aufdrehen, okay.
Wasser wieder zudrehen und Schlauch abmachen.
Also,
das ist komplett falsch.
Benutze
mehr Emojis.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, wir machen das.
Wir machen das anders.
Kann man das nicht, konnte man das nicht mal wegklicken?
Benutze
Twitch-Emotes in der
Erklärung, wie
zum Beispiel kekwe.
Ja,
ich muss, ich backupe
gerade im Hintergrund
meine SSD auf eine externe Platte
und dann installiere ich Windows neu und dann kann ich auch endlich
Battlefield spielen.
Okay.
Du willst die Heizung nachfüllen
Twitch Edition. Keck weh. Let's go, Chat.
Oh, cringe.
Chat GPT, Alter.
Bro, ich kann nicht mehr warm machen.
Easy Clap.
1,1 Bar.
Passt noch, aber bald
bisschen Wasser nachkippen.
Easy Clap.
Oh, ist das schlecht.
Wasser nachfüllen.
Pock U.
Die emotes geben überhaupt keinen sinn an der stelle
Heizung ausmachen kein meme das ist wichtig sicherheit first chat omega 0
wer macht das bei laufender heizung
Ist das tut ja weh beim lesen
Naja
Gut
Das lassen wir mal weg
Genug Kek-W
Warum ist eigentlich die Stream
Kiste aus gewesen
Okay wir machen jetzt gerade schon mal
Pac-Man
Package Updates
Bam, Package-Updates.
Leute, wie lange ist das letzte Mal Package-Update her?
Bestimmt schon vier Stunden.
Bestimmt schon vier Stunden, da wird es mal wieder Zeit.
So, Reboot.
Was steht an?
Wir programmieren das, was wir gestern in Go programmiert haben,
wovon es kein Wort mehr gibt.
In Java heute.
Oder probieren das zumindest mal in Java zu programmieren.
Wir clonen das quasi in Java.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht so easy wie in Go gehen, aber schauen wir mal.
Und dann, und wenn wir das gemacht haben, dann frage ich hier, dann frage ich meine AI.
Hier, LM Studio, frage ich dann, bitte konvertiere diese Anwendung in Java.
In Spring Boot Java.
Wobei, komm, wir können, sollen wir die gleich mal fragen?
Ich frag das gleich mal, mal gucken.
Mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Ich zeige euch erst nochmal die Anwendung für alle, die gestern nicht dabei waren, die wir in Go entwickelt haben.
Super simpel, die gibt es übrigens auch auf Shithub.
Official Prometheus-Lib ist kein Springboot, aber Springboot kann angeblich Prometheus-Metriken von Haus aus exportieren.
Müssen wir ausprobieren. Weiß ich selbst jetzt nicht genau.
So, guckt mal hier. Es gibt hier auf GitHub.
Was ist denn das? Microsoft?
Achso.
Hier, GitHub. Wobblors.
Wie habe ich das Ding genannt?
Monitorchamp.
Da.
Also, wir haben eine Go-Anwendung gebaut,
die ein Prometheus-Exporter bereitstellt.
Die kann man so aufrufen.
Ich zeige euch das.
Repo. Monitorchamp. Das ist die Go-Anwendung.
Da sagen wir jetzt go, run.
Da gibt man
ein Data-Dir ein
und ein Intervall und in der Zeit
Achso, das Verzeichnis gibt es gerade nicht,
aber es funktioniert. Mkdir, blub.
Und dann gehen wir mal hier rein
und machen hier mkdir eats
mkdir lulw
So, und jetzt haben wir eine Datei mit 10 Gig
angelegt nochmal drin. So, was das Ding
macht ist,
das ist eher so ein bisschen gebastelt gewesen,
Was das Ding macht ist, dass Scant die Verzeichnisse und gibt an, wie voll die Verzeichnisse sind.
Das brauche ich auf der Arbeit.
Unter anderem für Blockchain-Software, die ganz viele Ordner befüllt und das erstens saumäßig teuer wird.
Also wenn das auf einer Cloud-SSD liegt, wenn das zu fett wird.
Und es kann auf Probleme hindeuten, wenn manche Verzeichnisse zu groß werden.
Und das muss quasi als Sidecar in einem Kubernetes-Pott laufen.
Deswegen habe ich, und das werde ich auch in Go machen, aber hier wollte ich das gestern
einmal ausprobieren.
Also im Endeffekt scannt das Ding ein Unterverzeichnis und zeigt dann für die direkten Unterverzeichnisse
dort an, wie voll die Dinger sind.
So und das Ganze läuft dann als Prometheus Exporter.
Guckt, wenn man hier auf den http Endpunkt geht, davon, dann kriegt man hier diese Sache
als Metrik.
Es gibt eine Metrik mit jeweils dem Verzeichnis als Label und dann darunter die Größe in
Bites.
Das haben wir gestern gebaut.
Das ist in Go
auch relativ übersichtlich.
Wir können nochmal kurz durchscrollen.
Aber
wir werden heute eh dann durchgehen, weil wir das
Ganze ja nach Java portieren müssen.
Was sagst du zu Battlefield 6? Noch gar nichts.
Warum einmal
Go und einmal Java? Weil es geht.
Und weil die sich eigentlich gewünscht haben,
das Ganze in Java zu machen, anstatt
in Go. Aber ich will es lieber in Go machen.
Aber dann machen wir es heute mal in Java.
Also von der App an sich ist es eigentlich relativ easy.
Achso, und auch wichtig, dass da Standard-Out Structured JSON-Logs sind.
Vielleicht müssen wir dann heute sogar Log4j verwenden.
Keine Ahnung, was eine gute Logging-Library dafür ist für Java.
Ist es Public? Das hier, ja, das ist Public.
Hier.
Wo bloß?
Block back okay das
Aber es bringt hat doch bestimmt auch gescheites logging mit dabei oder da braucht man doch kein extra logging framework
Wo bloß monitor champ
Also das ist relativ einfach
Es gibt command line ich zeig das zeigt es gibt hier diese command line argumente der intervall und port
und
Wenn die anwendung los läuft passt die command ozeanen argumente
und startet die Run-Methode, Run ist das hier.
Hier startet er im Background, per Go-Routine im Background,
die alle Duration-Sekunden, also in dem Fall 5 als Default,
alle 5 Sekunden das hier refresht,
ruft alle 5 Sekunden die Refresh-Funktion auf
und da kalkuliert er die File-Size.
Also das ist relativ übersichtlich
und wir gucken uns das jetzt auch gleich nochmal in Ruhe an.
Zumindest will ich das in Java machen.
Wendering ist nur, dass du externe Pakete in dein Projekt auflängst, dass es garantiert
starten kann.
Achso, du meinst also auch falls irgendjemand mal sein Git-Repo löscht oder sowas.
Ich verstehe.
ok ich glaube wir machen einfach wir machen ja war und die go anwendung meint das gleiche
in das gleiche github projekt rein wir machen jetzt die mkd go lang da da mussten wir den
ganzen krempel hier rein er geht geht ignore sollte schon im top level liegen bleiben wobei
die knoll kommt damit nach go lang da haben wir nämlich hier den kram und jetzt war hier ja war
Da haben wir nämlich alles in dem gleichen Repo drin.
Und jetzt gehen wir mit IntelliJ da rein und fangen wir an.
Wir machen auf dem vierten Desktop, machen wir mal Goland auf, das verspicken können.
Bei NPM kann dir das nicht passieren, by the way.
Die haben doch bei NPM ausgeschaltet, dass man Pakete depublishen kann, oder?
War da nicht was?
Dafür hast du irgendwelche Malware drin über NPM.
Äh, nicht RPM, NPM meine ich.
Über NPM kann dir das nicht passieren.
Du willst...
Das willst du als CLI?
Pico CLI Starter?
Okay.
Muss man nicht Add Component machen bei Spring?
Das sieht schon voll abgedreht aus.
I Factory Factory.
Okay, Leute, wir sind im Java-Land angekommen.
Das war in Go zu einfach.
Jetzt brauchen wir Final Factory Manager Singleton Pattern.
Scrollbeispiel runter.
Hier kommt...
Ah!
My command implements callable.
Aha.
Okay, das muss ich mir gleich in Ruhe noch mal
zur Gemüte führen, wie das
funktioniert.
Autowired.
War das nicht so, dass man das nicht mehr
verwenden soll?
Auto Weird.
Weird Champ.
Nicht.
Nee.
Wired Champ.
Das wäre doch mal eine Idee für ein neues Emote, oder?
Gibt das das als Emote?
Ich meine.
Weird Champ gibt es.
Aber gibt es.
Gibt es Wired Champ als Emote?
Eigentlich gar keine schlechte Idee.
Wire Champ.
Du hattest Schmerzen bei den Java-Words. Warum?
Ich hab das doch am Ende gar nicht schlecht hingekriegt.
Für das, dass ich noch nie was in Java gemacht hab.
Was ich machen will, ich will diese Go-Anwendung, das ist so eine minimale oder ziemlich minimale
Go-CLI-Anwendung nach Java umwurschteln.
Ach wegen des Chats?
Ja.
So, IntelliJ.
Brauch ich mal.
Ich hab schon wieder alles vergessen,
was ich in Java gelernt hab.
Ähm.
Ich hab sogar schon wieder
verpeilt, wie man überhaupt Projekte anlegt.
Wart mal.
New?
Project. Okay, okay.
Wir wollen nach Repos.
Monitoring Champ.
Nein.
Hä?
Repos Mon.
Monitoring Champ.
Java.
Da wollen wir hin.
Project will be created.
ähm, Name, ja
Monitoring
Champ, heißt der da auch
ok, äh
und jetzt, Java, Kotlin
ok, nächsten Stream machen wir das
Ganze dann nochmal, aber dann in Kotlin
Group, Kekvi, Wobblors
perfekt, Monitoring Champ
Kekvi, Wobblors, Monitoring
allerbeste, genau
Java, 25, ja wenn schon
dann das neue.
Und dann in Skala.
Was kommt als nächstes? Erlang oder...
Erlang ist für alle
Klammer-Enjoyer.
Groovy. Groovy kann ich sogar
ein bisschen. Ich hab mal für Confluence
was in Groovy.
programmiert
Da genau das danach aus
Slim beats du hast erfasst
Aber ich werde ich werde das auf der arbeit noch mal basteln also das ist ja nur dass ich mal kurz grob geguckt habe wie es funktioniert
so an den moment wir wollen nicht wir wollen nicht cradle wir wollen maven
haben weil das das einzige ist wo ich halbwegs weiß wie es funktioniert
so next next next ok jetzt brauchen wir diese starting dinger was brauchen wir
denn hier alles gibt es console console application gibt es nie gibt es nicht
vielleicht gibt es da irgendwas was ich brauche hier als anscheinend nicht hier
observability monitoring oder sowas hier prometheus das will ich haben
spring boot muss man auch nehmen muss das nicht aber das ist das einzige wie ich weiß
wie man die anwendung erstellt genau prometheus das war auf jeden fall haben ok dann create
bam.
This window.
Zack.
Da sind wir.
So.
Help MD fliegt erstmal weg.
Bam.
Wer braucht schon Hilfe?
Git ignore steht jetzt drin.
Alles weg.
Git attributes.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wofür das überhaupt da ist.
pico cli ja das habe ich jetzt schon ein paar mal gehört im chat
ist das linux breaks 5% desktop share bei den kokonas open source search against
ohne scheiß das kann nur gut sein unterm strich für uns umso mehr das ganze verbreitet ist umso
mehr wächst der druck beispielsweise auch spiele mit anti cheat unter linux lauffähig zu machen
wenn du kein spring kam brauchst kannst du einfach plan ja war projekt machen ich denke
ich mache das trotzdem mit spring weil da vieles dabei ist was ich brauche zum beispiel monitoring
vielleicht auch Command-Line-Parsing, weil ich bilde mir ein, ich habe das im Hinterkopf,
dass Spring Boot so eine Config-Sache hat, wie ASP.NET Core auch,
dass das für einen quasi schon Command-Line-Argumente und Environment-Variablen passt.
Dass man dann irgendwie sagen kann, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie die Syntax richtig ist,
dass ich irgendwie sagen kann, hier plopp, und dann gibt es hier irgendwie so etwas wie Value,
oder oder wie ging das ich habe da irgendwo mal was drüber gelesen im
chaos string name und dann kannst du irgendwie sagen at well you oder sowas
irgendwie so geht soll das angeblich gehen
das müssen wir uns gleich mal ausprobieren wir schon dabei sind
heute mal quarkus an ich kann mir jetzt nicht alles an und wir machen das jetzt
mit springwood configuration properties in springboard lehung wieder beste seite
playung.com
Die Seite sollte mal ein bisschen
ähm
Dark Mode bekommen.
Chat.
Chat. Wartet mal.
Ich muss mal kurz was zu trinken holen.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Ist dir was mir aufgefallen ist, Chat?
immer wenn ich die kategorie auf software und game development stelle habe ich weniger zuschauer als
wenn ich das chatting mache dafür habe ich meistens wenn ich den software und game development stream
mehr leute im chat die plan haben von dem was ich das reibe das ist so das ist so komischer
trade-off irgendwie die kategorie guckt halt keine auf twitch
ok
da müssen wir jetzt erst mal gucken warum ist das hier eigentlich gerade
kaputt checkt dass jemand
Ist überhaupt nicht kaputt.
Geht doch.
Ähm.
Ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen
verpeilt.
Wie würde ich denn jetzt...
Wie würde ich in den Kram hier überhaupt
von Hand starten?
Gibt es sowas wie Java...
Java Run oder so?
Aber das kann man sich doch hier bestimmt abgucken.
was führt er denn hier aus?
Aha, ne.
Ne.
Man muss das doch irgendwie
mit Command einstellen können.
Okay, Moment.
Der erwarte Standard Milch ein...
Alter, was?
Schon das Jetbrains-Design gesehen?
Nee.
Hä?
Sieht das nicht schon jetzt so aus?
Ach so!
Ah!
Ah, ich weiß nicht.
ein bisschen besser lesbar ist es schon also sieht auf jeden fall moderner aus
du musst mir kein link schicken ich finde das schon raus wie das funktioniert etwas
meint ihr was sieht besser aus so ist es jetzt so wird's
also ich muss sagen bauchgefühl sagt mir das alte gefällt mir besser aber rein objektiv
gesehen würde ich sagen das neue ist irgendwie moderner und konsistenter
wir werden es erleben
spring gut cli application
spring boot console application auf geht's spring boot starter das haben wir ja schon mal drin
ach nee muss ich das noch in kluden habe ich das nicht in kludet spring boot starter gegen
das nochmal POMXML.
Ah, ich hab den Springboot
Starter gar nicht included.
Übrigens, eins muss ich ja mal sagen,
bei der ganzen Java-Geschichte, also ganz im Ernst,
Dependency Management
ist ja abgrundtiefer Schrott.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Lasst uns das mal kurz vergleichen.
Also in Java, wenn ich was
hinzufügen will, muss ich mir auf
irgendeiner Seite diesen Dependency
Block hier raussuchen.
Den kopiere ich dann
irgendwo hier rein.
Dann muss ich da oben draufklicken
und dann synkt er das. Von Hand
wäre das wahrscheinlich noch viel, viel ekliger.
So, und jetzt passt mal auf.
Java Enjoyers.
Wie einfach das in .NET geht.
Ja, so, machen wir mal irgendein x-beliebiges .NET Projekt auf, mit viel zu großer Schriftart.
So, irgendein x-beliebiges .NET Projekt.
Und jetzt, passt auf, jetzt gehe ich einfach hier drauf, auf Nougat.
Und sage, ich will Spectre Console oder so installieren.
Zack.
Plus.
Install.
Fertig.
Guck und schon.
Habe ich das hier.
Easy.
Also da muss man echt sagen,
das ist viel schöner in .NET gelöst
als das hier.
auszudrehen exekutiert java mit maven dann
monka ist jetzt wird es aber high high iq mäßig aber gucken vielleicht komme ich
ja selbst darauf wie das funktioniert console application implements command line runner watt
Wenn wir Spring Boot Applikationen exekuten, die sind auch gut, die schreiben gar nicht
wie man exekutet.
Okay, Chat was anderes.
wollen wir überhaupt command line argumente haben letztendlich wird das ding ja eh keiner
so aufrufen bevor man da jetzt ewig rum machen ich glaube wir konzentrieren uns
mal eher auf die funktionalität bevor man da jetzt ewig rum machen mit command line argumenten
aber ich probiere das mal aus was muss ich maven clean package
Aha.
Was ist denn das überhaupt?
MonkaS.
Das ist nur ein CLI-Rapper, aber für was?
Was ist das überhaupt alles?
Okay, also das ist das Next Level High IQ, so ein Ding per Command Line zu starten.
How to start Spring Boot Application from Command Line.
spring boot run aha
exzellenz
okay das heißt wenn ich da jetzt klappt mir das mal aus spring boot run
Wo ist denn überhaupt was da jetzt?
Warte mal, wie geht das noch?
Print?
Ne, äh...
System? Out, oder?
Printline, so.
Keck W.
So, und jetzt sollte das ausgehen, oder?
Keck W. Ja, macht er auch.
Okay.
Warum spuckt der denn so 30 Milliarden
Dinger aus?
Was ist denn in Target?
MonkaS, was ist das alles?
Java-Krams, ja
South, ist das neu?
Oder ist das das Makro dafür?
Ah, das ist ein Makro dafür
Okay, also so
können wir die Anwendung schon mal runnen
Ist gut zu wissen
Mr. SNA,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellente. Hyper.
Ups.
So, und jetzt bin ich schon aufgeschmissen,
weil ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern kann,
wie man hier eigentlich weitergemacht hat.
Der startet jetzt
die hier.
Ach, da muss man jetzt
Add Component und so dran schreiben.
Moment. Moment.
Wir gucken uns das einfach ab.
Hier haben wir das doch gemacht.
Springboot Application Run.
Wie ging der ganze Krempel hier überhaupt nochmal?
Guck mal, hier habe ich auch schon mal Prometheus-Metriken gemacht.
Das brauche ich jetzt wieder.
Springwood Application.
Äh.
Wie hat man jetzt hier überhaupt irgendwas?
Ah, hier.
Schedule Task.
Ich erinnere mich wieder.
Ach so.
Haben wir das gemacht. Okay.
Das braucht der...
Also, mal langsam.
Ich will in Spring Boot...
Enable Scheduling will ich machen.
So, dann nehmen wir mal das.
Das schmeiße ich diesen ganzen...
diesen ganzen Mist hier weg.
so schedule tasks und ich will dass das jetzt einmal in der sekunde ausführt
ach hier fix trade nie das brauche ich doch dass der einmal in der sekunde
diesen kram
alle alle 1000 millisekunden hier wie fresh metrics so und da machen wir jetzt
irgendwie mal rein die flashing matrix okay jetzt mal ausführen es von ich meine macht
noch nichts aber das programm läuft und alle sekunde werden die matrix refresh diesen beide
noch gar nicht gibt aber wenn es diese entgebe dann würden sie jetzt refreshed sondern kommen
mal zur eigentlichen Funktionalität. Denn was wir machen müssen ist, in einem Verzeichnis gucken,
wie groß alle Dateien drin sind. Also im Prinzip wollen wir das hier, das hier wollen wir für Java
haben jetzt schauen wir mal welche da am besten ist wobei wir können also wir fragen wir fragen
mal lokal ok lokale auf meiner grafikkarte läuft akku ob da was gescheites rauskommen
Ja, auf, lade.
Nicht so lahm.
War die Festplatte voll oder warum braucht das so lang?
Oh, oh.
Heute Morgen war es so 50 Gig.
Please translate this Go-Code to Java.
Bam
Okay, doch zackig
Local AI
Also
Das ist der Go-Code
Der Go-Code, wir gucken uns den mal zusammen an
Dass man auch versteht, was der macht
Wenn du übergeben den Pfad
Ja, also zum Beispiel
Ups
Zum Beispiel .slashblub
Oder so
Und dann geht der quasi alles
Unterhalb dieses Verzeichnisses
Durch
das ist hier ein Callback
im Endeffekt wird das hier aufgeführt
für jede einzelne Datei, die in einem
Unterverzeichnis oder in einem Unterunterverzeichnis
oder Unterunterunterverzeichnis
rekursiv dann quasi
alles durch
walkt er alles
durch und dann guckt er
ist das denn
kein Directory, also
im Endeffekt ist es eine Datei, gibt es auch sowas wie
isfile, wäre vielleicht
sinniger, ne
Wenn es kein Directory ist
Dann
Add
Die Size von, also dann ist es eine Datei
Wenn es eine Datei ist
Dann add die Size hier oben zu diesem Counter
Und so zählt er quasi
Von allen Dateien in einem
Verzeichnis und das sind
Unterunterunterverzeichnisse
Wie groß die Dateien sind und dann kommt
Am Endeffekt raus, wie groß das Verzeichnis
Insgesamt ist
So und das wollen wir jetzt in Java haben
Schauen wir mal, was Gwen dazu sagt.
Also, Public Static Long Deer Size.
Wir fragen jetzt nochmal...
Der hat es nicht so ganz gecheckt.
Wir fragen jetzt nochmal Chat-GPT und meinetwegen auch nochmal Perplexity oder sonst was.
ok der chat steht ja voll auf perplexity können auch mal fragen sagt also was sagt denn was sagt
denn jet gpt zu public class die utils die es als files walk file tree das ist ja mehr oder weniger
Also das ist schöner hier, oder?
Files, Walk, File Tree.
Simple File Visitor.
MonkaS, was?
Ich glaube, da müssen wir doch uns was eigenes bauen für.
Files, Walk, File Tree.
Simple File Visitor.
Simple, obviously.
Das ist doch kein gültiges Java, oder?
Der schreibt hier innerhalb von der Funktion irgendwelche Overrides?
Doch. Ja, das ist wirklich gültiges Java.
Okay, probieren wir das mal aus.
Machen wir das doch mal selbst.
Also, void. Ach ne, Moment.
Haha, das geht natürlich nicht. Das muss hier quasi jetzt irgendwie als Methode rein.
Evoid, Dear Size.
Das ist das Blöde, wenn man sich zwischen so vielen Sprachen hin und her wechselt, man bringt die Syntax durcheinander.
Warte mal, Return-Wert in Java? Ne, äh, ne, mein Return-Wert ist vorne, ja.
und 64 gibt es nicht in 60 gibt es das und okay das ist ein guter stadt haben
die es als string path so ach nee moment path string alter so ok
So.
Walk.
Files.
Was war das?
Punkt.
Typischer Vibe-Coder.
Walk, File, Tree.
Gibt es...
Warte mal. Chat, Chat. Moment mal.
Warte mal.
Man konnte sich doch Hilfen dazu anzeigen lassen.
Wie war das denn nochmal?
Man konnte sich doch...
Man konnte sich doch hier
irgendwie die...
Ne, ne. Man musste das irgendwie
runterladen vorher, oder?
Endpoints, Maven,
database muss man nicht irgendwie es docs runterladen
drittes von links das download sources and documentation sources and
documentation okay bm es habe ich gesucht
jetzt können wir uns nämlich gleich auch die hilfe für die verschiedenen
funktionen anzeigen lassen was ja durchaus sinnvoll ist okay files
wie lässt man sich denn hier die
es muss doch eine hilfe dazu geben
Da gibt es keine Hilfe zu.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Das ist aber komisch.
Ja, hier habe ich eine Erklärung zu.
Guck.
Hier kriege ich eine Erklärung zu
Wenn ich drüber gehe mit der Maus
Aber hier Files
Walk irgendwas
Gehe ich mit der Maus drüber
Bam nix
Da gibt es einfach keine Hilfe für
Kann das sein
Ah
Ha
Da gibt es
Nicht wirklich
also max depp
kann man kann man da irgendwie sagen minus 1 was ist der unterschied zwischen walk und
Walk, File, Tree, Path, ist irgendwie voll umständlich, okay, Walk, File, Tree, Rooted,
at a given starting file
also
heißt im Endeffekt
warte mal
hä?
Das ist voll Next Level.
Also.
Ich versuch das jetzt mal.
Was will der hier von mir?
Path.
Also wir machen das jetzt mal so.
Ich leg jetzt hier mein Unterverzeichnis an.
MKDier Blub.
mk dir club easy und da haben wir keine ahnung club wie sie machen der datei
drin die 1 heißt mit 10 gig warum eigentlich immer 10 gig will ich
unbedingt meine festplatte voll kriegen
was macht eigentlich meine
start also hier in blubb in blubb starten wir dann
Was war das?
Ah, genau.
So war das.
File, Visitor Option.
Follow Links.
Und wenn ich das nicht möchte, dass der Links Followed?
Unhandled Exception.
Surround with dry catch.
Ne, ne, ne.
Add Exception to Signature.
Ok.
return 1, mir jetzt wurscht.
Und dann rufen wir das auf.
GearSize.
Ja, gleich.
So, ich will jetzt einfach mal kurz gucken,
ob das überhaupt funzt. Was kommt denn da jetzt hier?
Was kommt denn da jetzt raus?
Hier, kann ich jetzt sagen, hier
Auto, ne Moment, Moment,
Sekunde.
Java.
War.
Wie in C Sharp.
Meine Güte.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit was in JavaScript gemacht,
was in C Sharp gemacht, was in Go gemacht
und jetzt was in, ja, da klickst du,
da wirst du einfach
verwirrt im Kopf.
Ja, Files.
Irgendwie so vielleicht.
Was will er denn jetzt hier von mir?
Was will er von mir?
Used without try with resource statement.
Okay, genau.
Meiner Wegen.
Was denn?
Files.
Ach, dann muss ich Close aufrufen.
Dann später.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Das ist sowas wie
Using in C Sharp.
Warte mal. Java, try
with resources. Das brauchen wir.
Genau.
Try.
Genau, so hier. Try.
Und jetzt so, ne? Und dann kann ich
hier drin auf files was was will er denn jetzt schon wieder ja mt3 block ich weiß doch zwei
erst mal kurz gucken ob ich es richtig formatiert habe format habe ich nicht sondern jetzt falls was
ist das stream part ein stream ein stream moment moment mein jetzt check ich nicht was
Aber man, ein Stream
Ein Stream ist so
Ach Moment, ein Stream ist nicht
Genau, das ist sowas wie Link
Das ist kein File-Stream, also nicht der Inhalt
Sondern
Sowas, wo ich filtern kann
Denk an die Pille
Chat, beste
High IQ Chat
Zack, Afk
Hillen nehmen
Monka
S.
Gleich wieder am Start.
Die Pille ist nur weiß.
Gab es bei der Matrix nicht, ich weiß.
Bin gleich wieder da.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Da bin ich wieder, jetzt muss ich nur noch was trinken.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Kann ich das for each machen irgendwie?
for each.
Das kann ich doch bestimmt auch loopen, oder?
Java
for loop
stream.
Streams versus Loops in Java?
Ja, mit for each, das habe ich gesehen,
aber ich will eine Schleife machen,
jetzt irgendwie keine...
Das ist ja irgendwie mit Callback dann.
Aber man kann doch bestimmt
Also in .NET könnte ich sowas machen
Achso, geht doch auch
Toalist
Ritzkoll
Dankeschön für den Sub
Das habe ich gesucht
Genau
Ah, fuck
Das war jetzt C++
guck und jetzt kann man sagen fein feines weil es ein objekt warum ist es ein objekt
ein objekt
Tourist
Ah, Tourist muss ich machen
Okay
File
Moment, hab ich da jetzt überhaupt
Size, hab ich da sowas?
Ne, hab ich nicht
Ähm
Das ist wirklich nur der
fahrt so wie es aussieht das heißt ich muss das ich muss dann auch irgendwie
file info oder so file info gibt so was gibt es weil info
weil
sei es
ok
das Ding ist jetzt nur,
ich muss checken,
dass das überhaupt Verzeichnis ist.
Okay,
dann machen wir das doch anders.
Files, where,
select,
map, okay, eins davon
muss es ja sein.
Okay, Filter,
Filter,
Ah, hier kann man...
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz schick.
Is regular file.
Is a regular file.
Das heißt, bei einem Verzeichnis
ist...
Ich könnte auch sagen, is not directory.
Ne, das geht nicht.
Aber Regular File ist ja eigentlich genau das, was ich haben will.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, das hätte ich mir schon gedacht, dass das nicht geht.
Das ist ja die Funktion, die er aufruft.
Beim anderen will ich ja quasi die Funktion aufrufen und den Return-Wert nehmen und umdrehen.
Dann müsste ich hier Lambda-Syntax machen.
So, dann machen wir das doch so.
Pilesize, dann machen wir das doch nicht so.
Und jetzt nicht for each,
sondern jetzt will ich wirklich Map machen.
Map.
Pile.
Nee, so, ne?
ähm
Size?
Funst ist? Ah, nee, dass Funst so schon mal
etwas hier gemacht hat. Also,
meine, meine
Idee war sowas.
Das geht anscheinend so in Java
nicht.
Ähm.
Wo ist das Problem hier dran jetzt?
Ach, size-weft
an exception, okay
Heißt im Endeffekt, ich muss sowas hier machen
Boah, das ist ja eklig
So, hä?
so das ist
ist er da sieht man dass ich keine jahre keine ahnung von von der abhab map to end
Bad return long cannot be converted.
Gibt es too long?
Okay.
Auch.
Er koteln.
Pink Mansonics.
Some.
Ah, ja.
Genau das will ich haben.
Es ist zwar nicht so schön,
aber es funzt.
So, Auto, Size.
Alter, was habe ich mit...
War!
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob das funktioniert.
South.
Size.
Was soll der Monitor?
Der kann schon was.
Das ist eigentlich ein Prometheus-Exporter,
der in Go programmiert ist.
Den übersetze ich gerade zu java was der kann ist als prometheus metriken die füllstände von
verzeichnissen zurückgeben also guckt zum beispiel
Und du startest das ding gut das verzeichnis gibt es jetzt nicht
Da müsste es jetzt ein verzeichnis geben dann wird es zu prometheus metriken zurückkriegen für alle unterverzeichnisse und wie voll die sind
Oder was heißt wie voll?
Wie voll kann man halt sagen, wie viel da drin ist.
Also wie groß die sind.
So rum.
Das funzt auch in Go.
Das ist gar kein Ding.
Ich will das jetzt bloß mal in Java machen.
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt hier so funktioniert.
Was hat er hier für Schmerzen?
Return value is never used.
Ja, ja, das ist schon okay.
So.
Run.
Okay.
Chat.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert.
Passt mal auf.
Äh, minus B?
Ja, guck mal.
Das stimmt genau.
Gibt es einen spezifischen Grund?
Ja und nee.
Es gibt einmal den Grund, weil es mich interessiert,
wie es in Java geht.
Und das zweite ist, bei mir auf der Arbeit stehen die unglaublich auf Java.
Und ich bin ja gerade ein bisschen am Java üben.
Ich bin ja kein hauptberuflicher Entwickler oder so.
Aber ist ein guter Gelegenheit, sich ein bisschen mit Java zu beschäftigen.
Nein, nein, ich bin noch nicht.
Es gibt noch nicht mal einen Termin für mein Praktikum.
Also Praktikum in Anführungszeichen, ja.
Ich gehe mal 14 Tage bei uns zu den Entwicklern und treibe da ein bisschen mein Unwesen und dann gehe ich wieder zurück.
So, aber das, guck mal, das funktioniert schon mal hier.
Das kann man aber doch bestimmt schöner machen, Leute, oder?
Das kann man doch bestimmt schöner machen.
Also erst mal, erst mal sagen wir hier Path.
So.
Und hier
übergeben wir. Kann man eigentlich
New Path oder sowas sagen?
Wow.
What the fuck. Alter.
path oft muss es anscheinend wirklich sein ok und slash club
willst du die ärger ich will ein bisschen mit basteln
uns das auch noch wenn die datei gesperrt ist wie sollen die datei gesperrt sein
also ich finde das hier ist super hässlich und nicht richtig lesbar
eben finde ich es hässlich kann man das nicht schöner machen wenn ich das hier weg lasse
es geht path of past get oder new file
und passt geht jeder finde ich das hier eigentlich auch ganz gut also das hier wäre dann quasi das
gleiche verstehe weil sie nicht was da besser ist weil wir lassen es wir lassen zwar so
schön wirklich schön finde ich ja nicht
aber ich finde man kann es halbwegs lesen oder bild danach ist regular file und dann
letztendlich werde es in go in go ist es auch gar nicht so viel anders
guck mal wenn man das mal mit go vergleicht das ist relativ das ist relativ ähnlich hier
seit wann macht der hier sagen das ist eigentlich relativ ähnlich guckt der ruft das info von dem
pfeil ab checkt ob es ein error ist und dann nimmt er die size das ist das ist mehr oder
weniger das hier der ruft die size nur dass es halt den jahr war kein error gibt sondern exception
Kann man das Map to Long nicht durch Summe ersetzen?
Ne, das geht nicht.
Das gibt es hier nicht.
Ich hätte auch gedacht, dass du sowas machen kannst.
Hier und dann.
Das ist anscheinend was, was zu diesem Map to Long gehört.
Aber das kann man trotzdem ganz brauchbar lesen.
Ich finde, das ist schon okay.
So.
Ja, du hast recht.
Wir könnten das
wrappen.
Get File Size.
Könnten wir machen. So.
Dann packen wir das da rein.
Jetzt können wir auch tatsächlich sagen, hier
So können wir jetzt sagen, guck mal
Das finde ich jetzt schon deutlich schicker
Probier doch mal die Variante aus.
Welche Variante?
Ah, was haben wir hier?
Moment, Chat.
Files, Filter.
Map to long.
F to file.
Length.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das eine gute Idee ist.
Liest der da nicht das komplette File ein, um zu gucken, wie lang es ist?
Da weiß ich...
Also ich würde vermuten, der Unterschied ist...
Hier...
Guckt er, was im iNote drin steht.
Aber wir können das mal ausprobieren.
Web to long.
Okay, warte mal.
File.
Nee, warte mal.
So, File.
Und dann...
To...
To File.
Gibt es da vielleicht Size?
Length.
return value is unspecified
if this file passt in unsere directory
and I
ok
also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe
wenn's, das ist quasi das, was ich hier
mir selbst gerappt habe.
Das gibt, das gibt, ähm,
das catcht quasi schon
die Exception und gibt 0 zurück.
Also ist das nochmal, nochmal schicker.
Oder?
Chat, das ist doch jetzt mehr oder weniger genau das gleiche,
wie das, was ich selbst gebaut hab.
Wir bauen das von gestern, den Prometheus-Exporter, den wir in Go gebaut haben, den bauen wir jetzt in Java um.
Einfach weil es geht.
Aber das gefällt mir.
Also machen wir es so.
Ja, finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Das gefällt mir so. Das ist schick.
So, jetzt kommt das nächste.
Wie macht man
Structured Logging, dass ich so schön
JSON-Output kriege mit den Logs?
In
Springboot. Springboot hat
auch bestimmt einen ordentlichen Logger dabei.
Also, der Prometheus-Exporter, den ich in Go gebaut habe, der kann so schön hier Structured-JSON-Logs ausgeben.
Das kann Spring Boot bestimmt auch.
Structured Logging in Spring Boot.
Hä?
Ja, genau. Genau.
Ja, mal langsamer.
Das alleine wird doch nicht funktionieren.
Wo ist denn überhaupt mein Application Punkt Properties?
ist ja
blogging strakt form und konsolen das soll jetzt funktionieren schon oder wie
das geht
moment ich mache ja ich mache ja print standard out
Aber prinzipiell scheint das zu funktionieren.
Ich brauche jetzt irgendeinen Logger.
Das haben die doch hier geschrieben.
Wo kriegt man den Logger her?
Private Static Final Logger Factory Get Logger.
Alles klar.
Private Static Final Logger.
Logger Factory.
Okay, welche der 3 Milliarden
Locker ist es?
Locker Factory gibt es
nur ein, anscheinend.
L-S-L
4J.
so soll das jetzt funktioniert
das
an den logger
Was?
Ne, das ist schon mal nicht richtig.
Ach so, Chorus geschrieben.
Logger, Info.
Info?
Und dann sagt man hier,
Okay, String, Size
So, Fragezeichen
Ja
So halbwegs funzt es
Okay, das will ich aber ein bisschen
Ein bisschen anders haben
Also erstmal hier Refreshing
Matrix
kommt immer weg.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
So. Also ich sehe schon,
wir fertig wären heute mit dem Java-Ding nicht.
Aber ich finde es ganz interessant.
Wisst ihr, bei Go habe ich den Eindruck,
das ist manchmal
vielleicht ein bisschen
ein bisschen
sonderbar
in Go, wie man manche Sachen macht.
Drücken wir es mal so aus. Aber das Schöne
an Go ist,
Was mir in dem Fall wieder auffällt ist, es gibt in der Regel genau eine Variante, wie man was macht.
Bis auf ein paar Ausnahmen.
Chat, wisst ihr, was ich merkwürdig finde?
Warum sag ich Logger Factory und warum kriege ich nicht per Dependency Injection hier einen Logger?
Komisch, oder? Kann ich nicht?
Sowas hier machen?
Ah, okay, das geht nicht.
Okay, das nicht.
Ich würde jetzt gerne das
bisschen schöner ausgeben.
Also, jetzt muss ich
mal kurz denken.
Chat.
high iq time wir haben jetzt hier was was meine directory size berechnet
bei der ich will es hier gar nicht drin loggen fällt mir gerade ein return size
so also
und jetzt will ich die
also ich will ja die die größe von jedem unterverzeichnis haben also von von den
den ersten unterverzeichnis und dann die größe davon also zum beispiel
wir machen mal hier 10 mb gleich besser datei 1 jetzt brauchen wir noch ein verzeichnis drunter
mkd 0 w da legen wir jetzt noch dann noch dateien an 123 ok so was ich haben will ich will jetzt
jetzt eine ausgabe haben verzeichnis ist 10 mb verzeichnis lulwe ist 30 mb also der inhalt von
da ist 30 wir können sogar noch mal hier gucken dass auch wirklich unter verzeichnisse von unter
verzeichnissen funzen da wobei das dann nicht angezeigt werden soll das heißt ich brauche
jetzt alle Verzeichnisse.
Du könntest deinen Stream anpassen
und Map-Return... Ne, ne, ne, ne. Ich will ja nicht
alle Verzeichnisse
haben, sondern ich will nur die oberen.
Also ich müsste jetzt hier quasi
nochmal eine Schleife drumherum machen.
Und nur die oberen
Verzeichnisse getten.
Also quasi
sowas wie...
Das machen wir mal. Deer Size lassen wir mal offen.
Warte mal, wirft das überhaupt noch IO-Exception?
Ah ja, das wirft noch IO-Exception.
By the way, wenn das IO-Exception wirft,
Da muss ich hier nachher einen Try
drüber machen.
Also,
lasst mal kurz checken.
Piles?
Ne, was habt ihr gesagt,
Chat? Path ist das, der neue Shit.
Blub.
Get root, get parent, get name, get name count.
Get file name.
For each.
Iterator.
Was?
Moment.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich sage
File
For each
Wie darf ich das verstehen?
Was macht der denn da?
Sound
Das muss ich mal kurz
Ich kann gerade nicht mehr tippen
mal ausgeben lassen was er da eigentlich von mir will
Okay, das sind doch alle unterfetzt ach nee das sind alle
Bestandteile von dem fahrt also immer die sachen die durch slash getrennt sind ach so
so. Ah ja, okay.
Das heißt, ich will
jetzt nochmal...
Okay, wir fragen
mal kurz...
Get all
Subdirectories
in a folder.
Steps gleich one.
Oh, ich sollte vielleicht Java hinschreiben
noch dabei.
in Java.
Wird geweibcoded
wieder.
Subtiers.
Folder.
Aha.
Das heißt, ich kann sogar machen
jetzt hier
to file und dann list.
Ah, nice.
Das ist nicht rekursiv, das ist nur direkt unten drunter.
Ah, kann ich sagen List Directory?
Ne, das geht nicht.
Aber ich kann jetzt sagen Filter.
Filter.
Äh
What
Was wird da von mir
Das ist Legacy API
Okay aber was ist die neue
Was ist die neue API
Moment ist das hier auch Legacy API
Warum ist die Legacy API einfacher als die neue API
Ja aber was wäre dann das neue
Ja, ich vollkommen wurscht, ob das Legacy-AP ist oder nicht.
Files-List.
Ah, okay.
Das ist natürlich noch schöner.
Das finde ich noch besser.
Files-List.
Jetzt muss ich wieder so ein Try-Ding machen.
Try.
Das kann doch nicht Surrounden.
Warte mal.
Files List.
Und jetzt kann ich sagen.
Filter.
Is Directory.
Genau.
Und jetzt habe ich.
Eine Liste.
Und jetzt mal.
For Each.
Ja doch.
Das müsste auch so hinhauen.
For Each.
Deer Size?
Äh, nicht Plup, sondern
ähm
Ah, warte mal.
Path?
Ah, das ist, weil das Ding jetzt in Error schmeißt.
haben wir wieder diesen kram dann sollte man das anders machen was gab es heute zu futtern
es gab nudeln mit lachs machen das mal anders das war jetzt
tool ist aber jetzt eine schleife drum
sagt dir was habe ich immer mit auto
heute ist ja schlitt ist ja schrecklich
tool ist
samt diers
und jetzt mal war das hier path read ich kann immer denken er hier sei es
und da können wir jetzt auch zwei catch drum herum machen warum
Was will er denn hier überhaupt von mir?
Ah, da fehlt
Try und so davor.
Und weiter?
Warum kann das Rider nicht für einen machen?
Muss Try.
So muss ich machen. Try.
Try.
Boah, das ist ja abfuck.
Files.
Ah ja.
Sub.
Yes.
Machen wir irgendwie so, ja.
Okay.
Warum meckert er jetzt hier eigentlich nicht?
Ach so, weil hier Throws IO Exception kommen kann.
Aber ich will ja hier gar keine IO Exception
throwen, sondern ich will,
dass der
Ah, wenn es das nicht gibt
Na doch, das ist schon ganz sinnvoll
Wenn es das nicht gibt, darf der ruhig sagen, gibt es nicht
Aber da hier will ich einen Try-Catch drumherum machen
Weil ich will ja, dass der weitermacht
Catch
I.O. Exception
Der soll eigentlich gar nichts machen.
Der soll einfach nur weitermachen.
So.
Wir sollen einfach nur mit der nächsten Datei weitermachen,
wenn das aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht klappt.
Was will er hier von mir?
Local Variable is redundant.
Ach, weil ich direkt returnen könnte.
Okay, alles gut.
Äh.
Was genau möchte mir meine IDE hier sagen?
Wow.
Okay.
Möchte mir nichts sagen.
Ist nicht mal grün.
Mal gucken, wenn ich das jetzt hier reformaten lasse, was er dann da draus macht.
Das war jetzt schon aus.
Okay.
Das geht doch.
Jetzt kriegen wir quasi die Sub...
Die Size von den ganzen Sub...
Directories.
Dann können wir das jetzt aus...
Hier haben wir mal Auto.
Ah!
Auto.
Meine Güte, wie komme ich immer da drauf?
Das ist ja schlimm.
Haben wir in letzter Zeit C++ gemacht?
Eigentlich gar nicht, oder?
C++ hat schon mein Hirn so zerstört.
Chat, ich habe mal eine Frage an euch.
Was findet ihr schöner?
War oder Auto?
Als so Wildcard-Variablen-Typ.
Also ich muss sagen, ich finde
War deutlich schöner eigentlich als Auto
Oder, oder Let
Die Rust-Entscheuer
Schreiben Let
Mut
Blub
Äh, I32 oder so
Irgendwie so sieht das in Rust aus
Okay, Chat
Let vs. War vs. Auto
Da müssen wir jetzt eine Umfrage machen
Sekunde
Ich mach mal kurz einen Unfall
Let versus war versus Auto
Let versus war
Irgendwo gibt es auch war
Ah, ich bin auch
War-Enjoyer.
Let, finde ich, geht auch klar.
Let ist so ein JavaScript-Ding auch.
Und in Rust ist es auch so.
Rust benutzt du auch Let.
Ich finde War auch ganz nice.
Aber Auto, naja.
In Ermangelung bessere Alternativen
in C++ halt.
War hat gewonnen.
Sehr gut, Chat.
Pog.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier die Size.
Dann geben wir die jetzt nochmal kurz hier aus.
Und mal schauen, ob das...
Size.
Size von allen Subdirectories.
Es gibt ja nur zwei.
Okay, Funst. Funst, schon mal gut.
Und das jetzt ordentlich loggen.
Logger.
Info.
Nicht wirklich.
Ja, Moment, wir wollen das ja ordentlich loggen.
Wir wollen das hier ordentlich loggen.
Das heißt...
Wie logge ich denn?
Kann man ein Array loggen?
Geht das?
Kann ich sagen?
Das müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Was ich mich gerade frage, ist folgendes.
Kann ich sowas hier machen?
Ähm.
at key value pass name pass heißt
at info
entry point verführt logging
Moin, vollgekackter Pisskopf.
Alter, die Namen werden heute immer besser.
Was macht denn
Ad-Info?
Check ich net.
Ich probier jetzt mal aus,
was du gesagt hast.
Weil es wird ja an sich net
funzen info at key value path to string und size mal gucken was er jetzt lockt
nix lockt er jetzt
Punkt Lock.
Ja, das will ich ja eigentlich erst später machen.
Wow.
This Path is 0.
Was?
Das ist überhaupt nicht schnull.
Wie kann das 0 sein?
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Warte mal, komm, wir machen jetzt hier 0 W.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht 0.
Was lockt der denn hier jetzt für Dinger?
Äh, gar nichts lockt der.
Ach hier.
Da steht's.
Der spammt nur mit ganz viel anderem Krempl hier rum.
So, was ich jetzt halt gerne machen würde, ist,
ich würde hier jetzt die Sachen hinzufügen.
Aber das soll mehr als eine Size.
Warte mal, ich bin gerade ein bisschen verpeilt.
Der sollte noch mehrere Sachen hier ausspucken.
Wir printen jetzt mal kurz hier Path.
Okay, das müsste ja funktionieren.
Genau, so.
Hier können wir auch so machen, oder?
Blub.
Geht das jetzt?
Ne, äh.
Okay, äh.
path to string
ich krieg das schon raus ich krieg das schon raus
das funst anscheinend okay
okay ja ist eigentlich genau das was ich haben will
genauso wie ich mir das gedacht hätte
ich muss das ja einzeln zusammenbauen hier locker ich glaube ich weiß was ich machen
muss ich glaube ich weiß was ich machen muss ich muss machen war temp ist immer beste variablen
namen info so und jetzt muss ich sagen
temp at the value ich schreibe da einfach nur so sei es
was will er jetzt bis alt ist was gibt es dafür result
Okay, so muss ich anscheinend machen
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Und jetzt sage ich am Ende
TMP-Log
So, so weit
Das ist aber hässlich as fuck, Alter
Was hat er denn?
Nested PS
Achso, ja, ja, okay, okay
Path
Was hat er hier mit meinem Plus String eigentlich für Probleme?
Was will er denn?
This path is null.
Was?
Ich hab's doch vorhin eben gerade geprintet.
Das ist überhaupt nicht null.
Ist das vielleicht Probleme mit dem Namen?
Ich nenne es jetzt einfach nur P.
genau das habe ich auch gedacht
because this path ist
was was
ich habe absolut keine ahnung was er von mir will
Was will der von mir?
Scheiß.
Ich hab noch nie einen Debugger gestartet hier drin.
Kann man wahrscheinlich wie in .NET auch so machen.
Äh.
Also, das ist nicht null.
Ich glaube, wir machen mit dem Key-Value
irgendwas falsch.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Ähm
Get file name
To string
Vielleicht mag der die Slash da drin irgendwie nicht
Seht ihr der mag die Slashes
Da drin nicht ich wusste es
Wobei was kommt denn
Jetzt immer blöde Fragen
Was kommt denn bei path to string überhaupt raus
Was kommt da überhaupt raus? Moment. Path of Blob Eats to String. Guck mal was da eigentlich rauskommt.
Blob Eats kommt da raus. Stimmt doch eigentlich.
Also das mag der nicht
Absolut Path probieren.
To Absolute Path, to String.
Ah, das geht.
Slash Plup, lul weh.
Das funzt anscheinend.
Ich verwende doch
meinen Logger.
Das finde ich aber irgendwie...
Also das hat mir in Go schon besser gefallen.
mit dem Loch. Aber das funzt.
Also im Endeffekt
kriege ich jetzt hier alles raus, was ich haben will.
Ich habe in meinen Logs drinnen stehen.
Ähm, Plup Eats
ist so groß und Plup Lulwe ist so
groß.
Ja, damit kann man
leben, denke ich.
Was hat er denn noch?
To Real Path.
Was ist denn das?
Was ist denn To Real Path?
Ach, das Komplette.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel.
Two.
Jetzt Pfeil nehmen.
Das finde ich eigentlich am besten.
Das Verzeichnis kannst du nur einmal geben, da drunter.
Ja.
Eats ist so groß.
Ich meine, Java spammt halt super krass Logs da gerade rum, aber das ist okay.
Ich baue den Prometheus-Exporter von gestern heute in Java um.
So, das funzt.
Das sieht zwar ein bisschen hässlich aus mit dem Gelogge hier, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Das sieht schon sehr abartig aus, aber es funzt.
alternativ kann man noch mal ausprobieren kann man denn irgendwelche arrays loggen
gescheit war logger punkt morning oder so kann man da jetzt sagen sagt hier ist
ja message sub tiers
das soll funsten
ey das funst
ja gut so halb
ok da kann er es formatieren
das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice
lassen wir das mal
finde das kann man es ist zwar echt nicht dass das hier gefällt mir überhaupt nicht
Aber es funzt. Das ist die Hauptsache.
Du willst ja bestimmt die Deers nicht top level loggen, sondern unter einem Key.
Ja, mach ich doch. Ne, mach ich nicht. Du hast recht.
Ja. Das mach ich in Go übrigens auch.
In dem Go Gegenstück.
Da wird...
Sizes wird dann, da gibt es Sizes und dann gibt es ein Result, wo das alles drin steht.
Also will ich im Endeffekt, okay, wir machen mal eine Map daraus.
Results, irgendwie so, gleich, new, map, nee, warte mal.
Oder doch so?
Path.
Und Long.
Okay, so findest du es schon mal nicht.
Argument cannot be a primitive.
Replace Long with Java Long Long.
Geht nicht.
Warum?
Ah, Hash Map.
Map ist das Interface.
so und jetzt schreiben wir hier wie salz oder p wenn n2 übrigens wieder ausgeschrieben
Path gleich size. Wäre ja auch zu einfach, wenn das so funktioniert. Require-Typ int. Was? Int? Willst du mich verarschen?
Geht das so nicht?
Results
Put. Alles klar.
So und jetzt können wir hier sagen
Logger
Log Info
Results to String eher nicht.
Jetzt sagen wir hier Sizes
results
ach nee
so schön ist das jetzt
guck mal was da jetzt rauskommt
äh
das ist nicht das was ich haben will
ich will ja eigentlich dass das
jason mäßig ordentlich lockt
als will er das naja also das ist so schön ehrlich gesagt würde hätte ich gerne dass
da jetzt das chasing ding reinkommt aber dass das kann der locker glaube ich nicht oder format
Formats, Mach wieder mit Logger, add, info, add, key, value, sizes, warte mal,
Add Info.
Add Key Value.
Guck mal hier, Sizes.
So will ich das haben, hä?
Log.
Äh, nee.
Nee.
Okay, ich sehe, dass das in Java tatsächlich komplizierter ist, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ne, das ist doch richtig so.
Das ist doch richtig so.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich war gerade für...
Das ist doch genau richtig so.
Genauso will ich das haben.
Hier, Sizes, blub blub.
Ja, genau so, das ist richtig. Easy.
warum man da at info at key value machen muss und das nicht direkt in dem in der
anderen methode oder aber es funktioniert das finde ich doch jetzt schon deutlich schöner so
wie es ist was mich davon abhält check mk zu benutzen hauptsächlich das web interface
Das finde ich so schick, das gefällt mir.
Wie habe ich es in Go gemacht? Hier Refreshing.
Kann ich jetzt noch hier sagen Refreshing davor und dann?
Ah ja, hier Message, Refreshing Sizes.
Genau so will ich das haben.
Genau so ist gut.
So, jetzt haben wir hier das Logging.
Das gefällt mir schon mal ganz gut.
Wir haben jetzt zwar noch keinen Prometheus-Exporter und nichts,
aber so die Basic-Funktionalität von Verzeichnisgrößen zusammenrechnen,
haben wir schon mal.
Das heißt, das Wichtigste ist schon mal da.
So, jetzt kommt der Prometheus-Exporter.
Den können wir uns abgucken, weil sowas haben wir schon mal gemacht.
Irgendwo hier.
Hier.
Custom Metric Service.
Okay, wir sind ja in Java.
Da muss das natürlich ein bisschen komplizierter sein.
Custom Metric Service.
Schauen wir mal.
Packen wir das Ganze hier nochmal rein.
Add Component, Custom Metric Service, Counter.
Ja, wir machen mal testweise irgendwas.
By the way, wie kann ich den überhaupt dann abrufen?
Da brauche ich doch einen Web-Endpunkt, damit ich den Prometheus-Exporter abrufen kann.
Ich stehe jetzt vielleicht hier in Application Properties.
Ah, Management Endpoints, Webs, Exposure.
Brauchen wir noch.
So ein Krempel hier braucht man anscheinend noch.
Ich starte das jetzt mal.
Net Stat.
Ja, aber also, fuck.
Auf welchem Port läuft das überhaupt standardmäßig?
Hast du eigentlich Betten noch nicht?
Bet, Toys, Spring, Boot.
Wir müssen mal kurz die Hilfe lesen.
So.
Okay, das muss man anscheinend wirklich immer hinzufügen.
90, 90 ist der Port.
Okay, Moment.
Application Properties.
80, 80.
Komm mal, nix
90, 90 auch nix
80, 80 auch net
Der lauscht noch nix
Da lauscht nix
Aktuator
Ach, da haben wir es doch noch, guck mal
Vom letzten Mal
Da lauscht aber nix
Das liegt daran, weil ich kein Web-Zeug hier hinzugefügt habe.
Kann das sein?
Irgendwas habe ich hier noch vergessen.
Wie mache ich das denn hier?
Websocket-Config, das wird es nicht sein.
Schedule-Task.
Eigentlich nichts.
Was habe ich denn vergessen?
Ah, das ganze Zeug habe ich überhaupt nicht drin stehen.
Spring Boot, Starter, Actuator, Mikrometer, Registry, Prometheus.
Das habe ich hier nicht drin.
Das wird sein.
Kekiava.
Wo muss ich jetzt hin?
POMXML.
Die ist drin.
Der Aktuator fehlt noch.
Zack.
Jetzt aber.
Ist der Aktuator am Start?
Was will der hier eigentlich?
Oh ne, da oben ist er ja.
Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich starte den mal hier drüber.
Vielleicht geht es dann besser.
Ah ne, erst mal abbrechen.
Also, der startet irgendwie nicht.
Was mache ich falsch?
Ich habe es ja schon mal hingekriegt.
Guck mal in den Logs, was er sagt.
Ja, nicht wirklich
Java Enjoyer.
Er sagt ja auch nicht Startup und Port.
Default CLI.
Was habe ich denn hier gemacht?
Oh, let's go.
Service.
Habe ich irgendwas vergessen beim Starten mit anzugeben?
Spring Boot Application?
Ne.
Ist eigentlich kein Unterschied hier ne? Spring Boot Application ARX.
Spring Boot nicht, ja.
Du hast kein Spring Web ausgewählt, das ist richtig, ja. Aber ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das braucht. Wir können das ausprobieren.
Oh, Vulnerability Font, Webstarter, machen wir rein, vielleicht braucht man das wirklich noch.
POMXML
Schauen wir mal jetzt.
Ah, okay.
Web muss man manuell hinzufügen.
Aha.
Okay.
Und da gibt es jetzt auch mal
Mein Custom.
Ah, hier, guck mal. Custom Matrix Name.
Wie soll man das rausfinden?
Das ist bei Java ganz einfach.
Du musst die Sachen schon wissen oder du hast gelitten.
Was für Pech.
Das ist nur für Eingeweihte.
Du musst zum Tutorial-Googler werden dafür.
Okay, die haben ja meine Custom Metric.
Alles klar.
So und der muss jetzt geupdatet werden, dieser Custom Metric Service.
Der Custom Metric Service, der wird geupdatet, den muss ich mir jetzt injecten.
Den muss ich mir jetzt hier injecten.
Also nicht Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, sondern Dependency injecten.
Und zwar, da muss ich mir den injecten.
Was ich da dann inkrementen kann.
Create Field.
Ich weiß, die Sharp Style.
Was will er jetzt von mir?
But never exist.
Okay, und jetzt updaten wir hier drinne Custom Matrix Service, Increment Custom Matrix Counter.
So, das heißt, es sollte, eine Sekunde sollte das jetzt eins hochzählen, Clay.
Ja, Pfunst.
So, natürlich wollen wir hier keinen Counter haben.
Sondern wir wollen...
Lass mal kurz gucken, wie man hier Custom Metrics macht.
Wir wollen keinen Counter haben, sondern...
Gorge, Multi Gorge, Gorge.
Das wollen wir haben.
Wie fandst du das jetzt?
Bilder.
String Name.
Wie habe ich es genannt?
Deer?
Wie heißt es bei Go?
Deer Size?
Deer Size Bites.
Okay.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen mag er das jetzt aber nicht so genau.
Warum nicht?
Supplier.
Was will der von mir?
Also ich finde es in Java oftmals nicht so klar, was man hier als Parameter will.
metric name des value
verstehe also außerdem ist das hier schon mal
hier sei es ja alles was den jetzt tag
und das brauche ich hier so was wie value aber mein value ist doch
Atomic Int.
Chat, das verwirrt mich jetzt, wie das funzt.
Ich will ja da
verschiedene Labels angeben können
und sowas.
was will denn jetzt hier von mir bis in return angehen das setzt der wert den man hier zurück
Return 1.
Ich weiß es.
Das wilde Ding von mir.
Return 1.
Return.
Value.
Ich sehe, das ist ziemlich High IQ sowas zum Laufzucker.
Was? Alter.
Der sagt einfach nur hier
This Value.
Und das mag der aber nicht.
Warum nicht?
Abgekackt.
Meinst du, wir sollen mal die AI fragen?
Okay.
Das geht schon, weil du den Bildern nicht zumachst.
Ah.
Weil ich nicht Register sage.
Ach so.
Aha.
Ich verstehe.
Das mit Dis-Value trifft es jetzt ja nicht so genau.
Ich will ja verschiedene Values mit Labels haben.
Labels will ich haben.
geht nicht, oder?
Warte mal, ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken, was hier zurückkommt.
Wow!
Achso, ja gut, das geht natürlich nicht.
Das kommt mal weg.
das ding heißt die es als beiz ja das ist doch richtig aber ich will die
labels ja dynamisch vergeben nein die haftbefehl doku habe ich nicht gesehen
habe ich heute morgen witzigerweise gerade gefragt im stream ob die sich
lohnt zu gucken und haben alle gesagt ja dies richtig gut also wahrscheinlich
gucke ich mir das noch an. Hafti Abi.
Frankfurt, Goethestraße,
Louis Vitor Store, zahl die Kollektion
bar, fick auf Sponsor.
Das Einzige, was ich kann
von Hafti wählen.
So, also irgendwie finde ich das gerade ein bisschen hakelig,
das zu benutzen.
Kann man denn hier nicht so was sagen,
wie
Hier
Label
Tag
Ne
Value
Ja das will ich doch gar nicht
Ich will
Ich will mehrere Values setzen
Brauch ich da einen
Gorge Vector wie in
Wie in Go oder
Moment
das muss ich jetzt muss ich jetzt mal kurz checken wie heißt das ding java mikro meter
labels
aus ukraine mikrometer gold ist change dynamic linie aber genau das ist die richtige frage
multi gout
Multigouch.
Aha.
Multigouch ist das Richtige.
Oder Gorge.
Oder wie auch immer man da spricht.
Multigorge.
Okay.
da kommen wir doch der sache jetzt schon näher jetzt haben wir einfach hier irgendwie set value
for
label
string
long value
ist ja Java, string
so und da
setzen wir jetzt
wir machen
dann noch
so und da können
wir jetzt sagen
Wie fandst du das jetzt?
Was?
Okay, das wäre jetzt auch viel zu einfach,
wenn man da Set Value machen könnte.
What?
Ich habe legit keinen
blassen Schimmer von mir, was der will.
Ah, hier muss die ganzen...
Ich kann doch die Tags noch gar nicht angeben.
Die weiß ich doch noch gar nicht.
Ach doch, die Tags kann ich angeben.
Die Tags sind Label.
Tag ist Label, das weiß ich schon
Oder Directory ist das
Nicht?
Expected two arguments
Okay, da bin ich echt zu dumm für.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Was macht das da?
Was passiert da?
Register?
Result Set.
Was ist Result Set?
Wo kommt das her?
Wo, wo, wo?
Result Set?
Was ist das?
Das ist echt high IQ,
dieses Ding zu benutzen.
Aber ich kann es doch noch nicht taggen da oben.
Hier findest du das mit Tag ja nicht.
Hier oben kann ich es noch nicht taggen.
Hier oben weiß ich doch noch gar nicht, welche Sachen es gibt.
Was ist Result Set?
Das check ich nicht.
Okay.
ähm
Response vom DB-Call
Okay, wir gucken mal kurz mit Register
was der da eigentlich von mir will
haben wir nicht eben noch hier ein schönes deck overflow
Ja, okay.
Das ist die gleiche Frage, genau.
Wie jetzt?
Moment.
Ist das denn hier ernst?
Okay, wait a minute.
Das kann ich mir eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen.
Moment.
Ich soll das jedes Mal neu registern?
Might not have been initialized.
Gleich 0.
Lul.
ja geht das so
meter registry und jetzt sage ich einfach tags tags label
und dann value das muss ein string sein oder ist das moment wie java long to string
java long to string
string value of
value of okay so
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
was habe ich falsch gemacht moment
das heißt natürlich nicht so das heißt jetzt set label
path
to string
und size.
Okay, bam.
Geht natürlich nicht.
Wäre auch zu einfach.
Also das funzt so schon mal nicht.
Obwohl die Registry, obwohl ich das jedes Mal...
Ja, warum funzt das nicht? Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das nicht funzt.
Ja, das ist wirklich weird, Champ.
Machen wir es nochmal anders.
Das muss aber eigentlich so funzen, ne?
Das müsste schon eigentlich so funzen.
Kann ich jetzt ein Feld machen?
Warum geht das jetzt nicht?
also der regis der register das jetzt gar nicht mehr
ein gottes ist aber dich gerade
wo ist das problem jetzt schon wieder
nee
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wasser fahrer wasser von mir will
Wo ist das Problem?
Ich hatte es doch vorhin schon mal laufen
Wartet mal kurz
Oh ne, ich kann nicht mehr weiter zurück
Nein
Was will das Ding von mir?
Wie muss das jetzt richtig aussehen?
Time?
Was? Bilder?
Be no suggestions.
Hä?
Was macht der Sender da?
Also ich muss es jetzt nochmal kurz checken.
Counter, das war doch easy.
Counter.Bilder.Blub.
So, Register.
Meta-Registry.
So, jetzt habe ich hier einen Counter gleich.
Der nicht Blub heißen soll, sondern...
Ich will einen Prometheus-Exporter bauen und das zu bedienen ist wirklich sehr weird.
Das funzt! Also mit einem Counter ist das easy.
Time God.
Ja gibt es nicht einfach nur stinknormale
Values?
der counter ist auch okay aber ich will den counter ja nicht incrementen sondern
einfach set auf den wert
Also das ist furchtbar High IQ, Alter.
In Java.
So einen Exporter zu bauen, Mann.
Was?
das ist wirklich super wird das verstehen
Maintain a reference.
ok
mikrometer gorge example wir hatten doch hier
ja da
da machen das
Also wie führen sie das jetzt aus?
Gauch.
Bilder.
So, Tier Size.
Und jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen Dis.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Ahnung was ich...
Get Gauch Time.
Also hier kann ich jetzt quasi so ein...
Return 1.
Das mag er schon mal nicht.
Expected one.
Okay.
Und zwar
ist mir egal.
Hey, ist Funst.
So.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt prinzipiell geht,
was ich da gestrickt habe.
Ja, ja, ja.
Funst. Okay, nice.
So, und dann
sagen wir jetzt einfach
Hacks
Wir machen das einfach jetzt hier unten rein
Das ist bestimmt nicht so gedacht
Aber gut
Dann nicht
Meta Registry
Wir legen jetzt einfach immer
Immer was Neues an
und offen das funst so dass jetzt haben wir tag label und value
was war das string value of
Okay, so
Jetzt Chat, Chat, bevor ich jetzt ausführe
Meint ihr das tut?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da für eine
Monstrosität gerade gestrickt habe
Meint ihr das geht jetzt, wenn ich es ausführe?
Hat schon geistig abgeschaltet durch zu viele
Aber, ne, ich glaube auch nicht, dass es geht
Oh ja
Ah, Moment
Ich bin ja bescheuert
Ähm, Directory
Path
Äh, Label
Das muss ich machen
So, und der Value
Ist das da
Jetzt funzt es auch.
Guck hier.
Dir gleich blubb.
Zack.
Wieso?
Ist das verpönt
in der Java-Welt?
Kommen die sich dann wie .NET-Leute vor?
Aber es funzt.
Es funzt.
Ich meine, irgendwie ist es schon ganz schön eklig, oder?
Dass man das jedes Mal neu
registern muss.
Wir probieren jetzt mal was aus.
Und zwar,
wenn ich jetzt hier hingehe,
nach Blub,
zum beispiel nach blubb so plupp ist aktuell gerade er hat zehn mb groß hier zehn mb jetzt
sagen wir hier eine neue datei mit einem mb anlegen dann müsste es auf einmal elf mb groß
sein checkt er auch ganz schön schnell aber hier das nicht gecheckt oder oder das hier gecheckt
ich habe jetzt nicht geguckt
das jetzt gecheckt
ne oder
ok das fonds nicht der update die prometheus logik mit rick nicht
der update die metrik nicht so nach dem motto wenn die einmal drin ist wird sie
nicht mal geupdatet meine güte ist das ein krampf aller
Ich hab jetzt echt keinen Bock mehr.
Das ist mir zu dumm.
Wir fixen das das nächste Mal.
Und dann werden wir das Ganze noch in Kotlin machen.
Und da werde ich wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Runde abkotzen.
Das Defcon-Video ist schon...
Ich gehe jetzt auf und esse was.
Ich habe schon hier angefangen zu futtern.
Ich esse jetzt hier mein Toastbrot.
Skala.
Ja, warum nicht Erlang?
Für mehr.
Ja.
Klar, Mann.
Das ist bestimmt gültiger Erlang-Code hier oben.
Wobei Skada ist doch auch so ein Ding, oder?
Mit zig Klammern.
Ne, wobei.
Geht doch sogar.
Oh ne, hör mal auf.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Haskell machen wir bestimmt nicht.
Dann mach ich ja lieber C++.
Das heißt schon was.
In nächster Zeit, wie gesagt,
kann ich wahrscheinlich unter der Woche nicht so viel streamen.
Aber Wochenende dann.
Boah, das wär abartig.
Also das in C wär schon abartig.
Das ganze Ding. Nur in C.
Ja.
Oder modernes C++ wäre, würde das Ding auch übelst eklig aussehen.
Weil C++ hat immer noch kein HTTP-Handling und so in der Standard-Library.
Das ist overrated.
Dieses HTTP, Leute, das wird sich nie durchsetzen.
Wir machen weiterhin IPX.
Aber dafür hat C++ in der Standard-Library auch nichts.
Okay, Chat, ich geh jetzt auf.
Sekunde.
Wartet mal, wartet mal.
Ich frage, das wollte ich die ganze Zeit
doch schon fragen.
Ich wollte meine lokale AI
fragen,
übersetze dieses Go-Programm,
hat Go das in der Standard-Lib?
HTTP-Requests, natürlich.
Du hast in,
du hast sogar in der Go-Standard-Library
JSON-Parsing und
also chasen serialisieren und parsing mit drin es gibt bestimmt gute http oder gute weiß ich
nicht aber http libraries für go für für c++ so warte mal hier translate translate this go code
to java spring gut
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was da rauskommt
Go hat nicht mal
Datenschub, doch klar
Das heißt da
Slices und ist vom Handling her
Vielleicht ein bisschen umständlich mit Append
Aber du hast ne Map
Hast du in der Standard Library
Also du hast noch nicht mal ne Map in der Standard
Du hast quasi Bestandteil von der Sprache
Ist das
Du sagst dann, wie war das Go Syntax mäßig
Wenn du ne Map brauchst, sagst du hier
Bloop gleich make
map string int so und schon hast du schon hast du eine hash map oder
ein dictionary oder wie auch immer man es nennen mag
guck blog string 0 w gleich 1 pfunzt das ist eine map was du quasi so sogar so eine sprachensyntax
dafür ja und liste ist so ähnlich liste kann ich mir aber die syntax immer nicht merken ich
Ich glaube, eine Liste von Strings ist so.
Nee.
So?
So, gell? Nee.
Fuck.
Die Syntax kann ich mir immer nicht merken.
War?
Blubb?
Ah ja, so.
So kann man es machen.
So würde es funktionieren.
So hast du eine Liste von Strings.
Du kannst jetzt sagen, wenn du da was anhängen willst,
sagst du hier Append.
Und schon hast du was an die Liste angehängt.
Das geht.
Also das ist auch schon wirklich lange in der Go-Library,
in der Go-Standard-Library mit drin.
Ich würde sogar so weit gehen und sagen,
das war von Anfang an in der...
Also belehrt mich eines Besseren,
aber ich würde sagen, das war sogar schon von Anfang an
in der Go-Standard-Library drin.
Okay, was macht hier meine AI-Geschichten daraus?
Ah, guck mal hier, das sieht ja tatsächlich ganz gut aus.
registry gleich meter registry
gauch bilder der macht es genauso wie wir das auch gemacht haben hier nur das
ist das dann irgendwie nicht aktualisiert.
Aber gut.
Was auch immer.
Chat, wir sehen uns
nächsten Stream. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.
Ja, es gibt zig Milliarden
re-implementierung für für viele sachen ja gerade go hatten super viele libraries
auf github aber braucht man nicht also für die basic sachen braucht man das
nicht die haben mittlerweile sogar in der standard library eine thread safe
thread safe map haben wir nicht verwendet bis dahin macht's gut cu